il n'y a pas d'âge pour se prendre à
rêver marie bientôt soixante dix en est
le parfait exemple
le 5 mai dernier cette habitante du
tremblay sur mauldre a pu réaliser son
plus grand rêve rencontrer des gorille
pour lesquels elle se passionne depuis
longtemps
c'était dans le cadre du zoo safari de
thoiry grâce à l'association rêves de
seniors que l'yvelinois avait contacté
par mail
j'ai donc pianoter sur internet et par
hasard je suis tombé sur f2 seniors je
savais pas du tout ce que c'était mais
rêve à paulette senior
ça m'a plu lancée début 2009 1 par
silver alliance rêve de seniors permet à
des personnes âgées de réaliser leurs
rêves
l'objectif derrière changer les regards
sur le vieillissement en france et
rompre la discrimination liée à l'âge
exacerbée par la crise sanitaire
actuelle rencontré beaucoup de personnes
âgées qui à là question toute bête c'est
quoi votre rêve nous répondait or vous
savez mon petit à mon âge on rêve plus
on vit est en fait cette phrase-là moi
ma propre sont profondément perturbés et
perturbe aussi tous les dirigeants
d'entreprises avec lesquelles je
travaille dans silver alliance parce
qu'on se dit finalement quand on l'a 65
ans on a encore 25 30 ans d'espérance de
vie devant soi et que à la retraite il
ya bien un moment où on peut rêver
d'entreprendre et de faire les choses
qu'on a toujours aimé faire sans la
contrainte du travail c'est vraiment le
bon moment lors de la rencontre à thoiry
mari a fait la connaissance des quatre
gorille du parquet y ait baha yacht en
bo1 wazungu venues des plaines de
l'ouest
elle a pu aller au plus près des
mammifères aux côtés d'un soigneur et
même les nourrir un moment fort en
émotions et j'ai demandé si je pouvais
moi avoir le privilège de donner de ce
fruit est ma tu m'as du pas de problème
gp un gant et à chaque fois donc qu'il
faisait bien il avait je leur donnais le
fruit et ça ça m'a particulièrement ému
ce qui est fort c'est de voir en fait
les étoiles dans les yeux de marie comme
on les voit quand on est père d'enfants
quand il quand ils croient encore au
père noël et des souvenirs plein la tête
pour marie qui lui ouvre de nouvelles
perspectives d
qui est désormais sa vie au gorille et
pourquoi pas aller les rencontrer dans
leur habitat naturel